weird west is a game built on giving the
player full control control that does
enemies and oil before setting them up
blades control the bury of the dead or
dig them right back up to sneak around
go guns blazing to be a hero a villain
or blow the doors off instead of finding
the key
it's an immersive sin and the core
principle of any immersive sim is to
give the player as much control as
possible to allow them to take their own
approach to craft their own story and of
course the ability to shoot absolutely
everything
[Music]
if you saw a coin on the floor you could
aim at the coin if you throw a bottle in
the air jump and start aiming at the
bottle that is raphael colantonio raph
for short he's the co-director of
dishonored director of prey and founder
of weird west development studio wolfi
for raph being able to shoot anything in
real time is one of the game's most
defining mechanics
but it also
sent the game
into development health there is moment
where you really think
are we screwed
when raph and his team set out to make
weird west they wanted to make the
actual genre of weird west westerns but
with horror and fantastical elements and
put it in an action role playing twin
stick shooters set in a fully 3d
rendered world
after all all of those things have
existed one way or another immersive
sims isometric rpgs twin stick shooters
all wolf i needed to do is just
combine them
what could go wrong
a lot actually
we initially had an idea for a stripy
top-down right 2d kind of thing all the
twin-stick shooters that i had played
back then like nuclear throne or some
other game where it felt like though i
had never worked on a twin stick shooter
it seemed like a soft problem right you
aim with one stick and while you move
with the other
and it felt like we could probably do
that in 3d it would be a little more
pretty you're not constrained to a 2d
plan anymore for for combat so you put
some elevations sooner or later you're
actually in a 3d environment like fully
3d not just for the rendering but also
for the gameplay but back then what was
happening is that we forgot that we uh
our plans for aiming system
was based on uh on a 2d system
and even some some twin stick shooters
that are actually rendered in 3d they
are still operate on one plan that's the
thing that
did not click with us with any of us
twin stick shooters operate on the core
principle that one analog stick moves
your character while the other aims
where you shoot
and that's it and that control scheme
has remained unchanged since the genre's
popularization with robotron back in
1982
there's a great game by the way now it
may have evolved from flat pixels to
fully 3d worlds but how they operate
function and move has remained the same
you point
and you shoot
weird west on the other hand
well they wanted to do things a little
different weirder even
as we implemented our our aiming system
it was quickly
uh
hell we quickly realized that we were
stuck uh because there was no game that
had pulled that off there was no game
where there were elevations and at the
same time you could aim anywhere the
same way you can in a twisted shooter
the aiming feature we thought would
probably plan like maybe four weeks on
it but unfortunately it probably took
more like four to six months
even more the problem arose one year
into the game's development putting raph
and his team
a pretty tough spot
it was out of the question to do to not
let the player aim at anything and at
the same time at this point was out of
the question to go back in 2d and that's
there is moment where you really think
are we screwed did we corner ourselves
in a way where
that's it we'll
never be able to make the game that we
were set to to do
the team tried a lot of different
solutions they experimented with a cone
system where instead of aiming a thin
line of sight the player instead
directed a cone relative to the player's
peripheral view
however it was never a one-to-one
representation of the player's intention
and what exactly they were aiming at so
they scrapped it then there was the
flick system where the player would
cycle through targets around them by
flicking the analog stick left and right
however cycling through every object on
screen quickly became tedious and
cumbersome for the player so they
limited the player to only being able to
target npcs
which was a no-go because it went
against the immersive sim philosophy of
giving the player the freedom to do what
they wanted how they wanted
so they scrapped that too
things
were not looking good one of the big
pillars of the game
was hinging on that thing to be a
success you know it was a lot at stake
it would have changed the we would have
had to
change the nature of the game severely
so that was not an option sometimes you
gotta make a big shift and you think
okay we give up maybe it would have led
to another type of game like because
sometimes from constraints emerges
something really cool but is it pride or
or a bit of uh yeah i don't know you
know a bit of ego or something
we're gonna crack that nut they poured
months of man-hours into trying to solve
this problem and we're on the verge of
changing the game entirely until
they had a breakthrough nobody believed
it was possible everybody was ready to
to give up it took us two two different
programmers uh to go through that and
the person who eventually found the
solution or at least the beginning of
the solution was it yen obey our
uh our lead animator surprisingly and he
thought forget about the 3d part it's
not it's not a 3d thing anymore it's
like we render a rectangle that is
constantly facing the camera and even if
you move the camera the perspective it
will always cut what is ev anything that
is under the that line that you get you
moving it's exactly like a cursor so it
becomes a 2d cursor even though it's
calculated with with with uh with 3d
stuff
instead of trying to figure out how to
aim in a 3d space using a 2d control
scheme they created an invisible line
tied to the right analog stick that
wherever the player pointed it it would
render anything in its path as if it
were 2d so regardless of elevation
whether that's an oil lamp on a table or
a vulture way up in the sky if the line
is pointed in its direction it reads as
though it is on a flat plane
[Music]
now that i'm talking about it sounds
like super obvious
but i swear when when you're stuck in it
with all the smart people around and
like most of the time i was like
i don't know
you know so it's funny that it came from
from an artist i think artists will will
tend to uh
not be paralyzed by the knowledge of
mass
they'll look at
the intention more than the engineering
behind it you know and so here he had uh
he had the great great solution for us
[Music]
now probably one of the most amazing
parts for me hearing this story is that
if i had not known about it i would have
just probably never noticed anything
really remarkable about weird west's
aiming system which is a good thing that
means raph and the wolf eye studio team
did their job
even still despite all the time they
sunk into the game's development to be
able to
execute on the vision they had intended
there's still a 2d mode you can still
just
click on overhead mode
play the game like that and i gotta give
it to him
i think it's pretty fantastic that they
still
allowed the option despite
all the work they put in you know
to what they intended in the first place
in the end weird west is everything it
had set out to be it's an isometric rpg
it's an immersive sim and it's a twin
stick shooter all at once something that
was deemed impossible during the game's
development that is if it wasn't for the
perception of an artist
[Music]
you